have to share my studio with a fatuous
twerp who shall remain nameless this
twerp has a name and it's august gutu
leibowitz clementine
you might know john hodgman for his
appearances on shows like parks and
recreation and the daily show or maybe
as the pc
in some memorable apple commercials this
morning all rise not literally because
he's a fake judge he joins us in his
fake official capacity
as the host of judge john hodgman it's a
podcast where he settles real-life
disputes on topics like
is chili a soup no his ruling agrees
with gayle king oh good no
is a hot dog a sandwich verdict on that
one
no i say although if the bun is torn and
it becomes two pieces of bread yes i'm
just looking at gail
this is wednesday there she'll be more
like this husband will host a free live
justice event at new york city's lincoln
center and he joins us now to settle
some of our own hot disputes uh judge
thank you for being here good morning
and yes please stay seated i'm just
so glad we're all awake just a regular
everyday american that's right um what
was the process like becoming a fake
certified official judge on the internet
uh very easy i got a podcast
is anyone so you're self-proclaimed
yourself like most experts operating in
america today i am self-proclaimed right
so the phd stands for piled higher and
deeper i have a bachelor's degree okay
in literary theory
no experience whatsoever what should
people anticipate on wednesday well i
and my co-host my bailiff jesse thorne
will get up on stage at damroch park
outside under the stars at lincoln
center
and we'll have litigants real life
people who have real small disputes get
up on stage and
give their sides of the story we have um
a wife and a wife uh one of whom uh does
not recognize daylight savings time
refuses to change the clocks even in her
own car the other wife doesn't like i
appreciate the stance on principle but
it could be confusing
we have another couple uh a guy and a uh
and his girlfriend he loves to take long
hot baths
and then lounge around in his robe on
the couch
for an hour afterwards
she doesn't like it
what's wrong with that he's against
leisure yeah what's wrong with that i am
inclined to agree with this guy he needs
to
steam off after a long hot bath she says
it gets the couch all wet i will ask
questions my suspicion is
he looks like a dork on the couch in his
robe
no there's things to do you're supposed
to be impartial judge john but people
say people listen to you on a regular
basis say whenever there's a dispute
between a husband and a wife you will
rule against the husband true
that is nothing to do first of all i'm i
like all judges i am not impartial okay
i do have leanings okay and if anything
i leaned in favor of husbands when
the show started
but i've been doing this now for many
years
and i have found through data
over
in heterosexual couples dudes are wrong
yeah almost always wrong i've seen the
scattergraph i like it you're always
wrong because they've always got schemes
he's got schemes absolutely true i like
that you say you take cases that are so
trivial and absurd that no one will
really uh take this on and i have a
trivial absurd please it drives me nuts
that when people open up the kitchen
cabinets and leave them open
now people could say gail just close it
but it just it makes me
it just is irritating to me if i walk in
the kitchen and all the cabinets are
open or the microwave sitting over jails
haunted girls no no no no no
no
this could be beyonce no no i'm going
back to when i was married and sometimes
when my favorite daughter comes she does
the same thing yeah i lived with someone
who did the same thing as well and gail
should we get over and i are friends no
no okay you and i are friends a hot dog
is not a sandwich thank you but if it's
torn into the two pieces of bread it is
sir
tony
i don't think we have time to get into
it okay all right uh we do have but it
does irritate you though the cabinets of
course their natural state is to be
closed and i don't want to be bonking my
head on them yeah yeah yeah good you
have to be mindful one of the potent set
of law of our show is yeah be mindful of
the work you leave for others okay you
leave a cabinet open someone else has to
close it either through their labor or
their accident bunk yeah what was yours
tony tear it up
if it gets torn in half it doesn't
you're still not going to ever cut it in
half you'd never order half a hot dog
with a cup of soup that's the difference
i'm going to continue to argue this one
fake internet judge john hodgman thank
you very much thank you for your honor
good luck on wednesday
i'm going to be there to heckle you on
the hockey i hope you will